good morning counselors uh thank you
very much indeed I'm just announcing
that the cabinet meeting is to start
we will start with apologies for absence
have we any apologies for absence today
we've got none
and disclosures of Interest
any disclosures for interest that
anybody wants to declare today
none it's the uh
delicately I might mention about the
concessionary permits item which is on
the agenda later for discussion is
possible members might have an interest
they wish to declare on that item
in my case I do not have a concessionary
parking permit but I am of the age where
I could ask for one and therefore I
declare the interest that I'm of that
certain age thank you
bearing in mind
um
that this matter could involve decisions
that directly impact on people of a
certain age
um I think it's appropriate to Grant a
dispensation to enable people in the
room to speak and to vote
um bearing in mind that if it wasn't the
transaction of business would probably
be interrupted
and I'm assuming that was the same
advice that was given when when the
decision was taken to remove it in the
first place
right continuing on
um we have the minutes we've got to
confirm this and sign the minutes of the
meeting aren't held on the 5th of June
um could I have somebody to approve and
second that we accept the confirmation
that
um David exposure yeah
okay
okay agreed
and were there any Matters from there
that to be referred to the council we've
got the from the planning and economic
development polio portfolio we have a
report on Wells one campus and the
supplementary planning document for
adoption and that comes over to
councilor coucher would you like to
outline that counselor capture
uh thank you very much chair
um clearly uh this is a a important
matter for this Council it's a very key
site north of wellsborn and the um
the uh the SPD that's been produced
um is a guideline for future development
on that particular site and the
development of which we hope will take
place by Warwick University
and it will fulfill one of our key
issues in relation to the economic
strategy that we have for for the
district and it will be a material
consideration
um for any planning application coming
forward and and I certainly would
recommend
members are supportive of it there are
three issues that I think have come up
in consultation and masses which I think
will be taken on board
one is the key issue of off-site
infrastructure and particularly roads
and transport
the a429 is obviously a key road that
passes this site and this will generate
additional traffic on that and we need
to look carefully at considerations for
that an issue that was raised I think at
ons about rat running through
Associated settlements also needs to be
looked at and one of the things which I
know as a local member for this area
we've been campaigning for for many
years we will be looking for the
completion of the cycle route from
Warwick to wellsborn which passes the
site as well the two other su's are
clearly in relation to power generation
this is a site with potentially going to
have substantial buildings on it and we
want to make sure that it is close to
zero carbon as it possibly is and the
third issue which is also extremely
important is
maintaining the Strategic gap between
the northern edge of wellsborn and and
the campus I'm very pleased to say as a
result of the consultation the Strategic
gap between childcat and the campus has
been improved and I think that's
welcomed and we need to make sure that
that also happens in relation to Wells
born too and with those with those
considerations chair I would recommend
that this document is approved
do I have any other comments on that
um and the the comments that I had
um have been answered by councilor
coaches I I was concerned about the the
transport infrastructure uh and making
sure that the energy uh on site was and
those questions have been answered has
there any are there any other comments
that before I asked that uh
um that we consider the document for
adoption and ask for that to be uh
formally approved and I'll read it out
and when I get to the right page
area so the recommendation that we have
to undertake and vote on today is that
the changes identified be approved
and the University of Warwick Innovation
campus strato upon Avon framework master
plan supplementary planning document
reformally adopted could I have votes on
that please
okay who's the host proposing sorry I
would propose that chair yeah and who's
going to Second it counselor Nigel Rod
I'll secondary I thought there was an
excellent
um review of the whole uh Mata osc and
on that basis I'll be pleased to Second
it thank you
Now we move on to the formal vote for um
whether or not we go to formally adopt
this SBD
thank you very much
that will be referred to council for
formal decision but you're recommending
it to council for adoption now thank you
we now move on for matters uh for
decision by the council and the first
one is from the environmental and
neighborhood planning portfolio which
covers concessionary parking permits and
with this is a report that proposes the
reintroduction of a concessionary permit
for residents of state pension age and
this one is councilor growcott and I am
aware that there are Ward members that
would like to speak to this as well if
that is once councilor grocott has
outlined her case thank you
thank you chair
um the concessionary car parking permit
um was
withdrawn in 2021 by the previous
administration so as part of our
Manifesto pledges we wanted to
reintroduce a statutory pension age
um
concessionary parking permit to support
the
um the older
residents in the district so part of the
um Pope the proposals is the fact that
it's going to be available for residents
of state pension age only there's going
to be a maximum stay of four hours
between nine to five and it will be
costing 50 pound per annum this will
actually allow people to use the
Bridgeway multi-story and Bridgeway
surface car parts which will allow
access to the Stratford town center and
the Stratford shop Mobility so that was
our proposals and we we did bring it to
the oversight and overview and scrutiny
committee and there were some questions
asked about the
um the costs how we come to 50 pounds a
month and other questions about what's
our achievement what we wish to achieve
from reintroduce business where we're
talking more the health and well-being
of the local residents
so this was discussed so we wanted to
move this forward I mean considerations
that came out of the oversight and sorry
view in scrutiny apologies was the fact
that this was not just a financial thing
but it was looking to allow encourage
more people of state pension age to come
into Stratford upon Avon which would
sort of help with the well-being of the
population
with the allowing more
contact with people and also to allow
people to come into the town center and
support the High Street and have more
interaction there with the older
generation
so we have had
we have had
um
feedback like I say and what we're also
looking to do is to
um
request that officers bring forward
report on the possibility extending the
parking secession to the wreck
removing the need for people to be
crossing the bridge
and keeping the traffic out of the Town
Center okay and also to look at
approaching Warwick District Council to
see if it would be possible to introduce
the reciprocal parking concession scheme
for the pensioners so
what our recommendations were that we
moved this board but with a um so we go
through statutory consultation against
the um items that we've already
mentioned the reports which will come
back obviously in September but also
have um officers look at feasibility of
extending the scheme through to the
recreation ground and the swans Nest car
parks to also support the um the
residents that are south of the river so
we're looking to do that and have a
report back at a later date
campus Rock
thank you chairman and I thank you
Lorraine
just a couple of things
um that I wanted to ask about
um
which I wasn't I was seeing there was
again there was quite a good debate
about that
um
four hours why why is it nine till five
I don't know whether the office was
answer that because I know we we get
free off street parking after these out
I think but and but the obstacle our car
parts are charged after that period
aren't they so I
um you know is there is there an area
that that we ought to I just wondering
what the logic is if there is one
um other than the off street parking uh
being free
yeah I think initially the four hours
was designated for people to be
volunteering in the charity shops and
because they were open from nine to five
that was our thinking
um obviously uh in tiny with where our
street parking on street parking starts
is free after six but that was my
understanding and let's create uh
obviously
yes that is correct so the original
proposal was looking at those that
volunteer so we was looking at a nine
till five window
um fully appreciate that the off street
parking uh is six o'clock so that may be
something that comes out to consultation
when we do the statutory 21 day
consultation that might be something
that's mentioned
um but yeah that was the thinking behind
that
so so
um it could conceivably be um any four
hours after the 24 hours in order to
allow people to be able to use
um use it for the evening without that
that one window the one hour window
between five o'clock and and six o'clock
when you can park on the streets
um potentially and Council
uh yes
almost the question I was going to ask I
mean if if we did if the first step is
to do this using the anpr in the one car
part that we've got to do that
presumably there's no technical
difficulty in changing that those hours
uh subject to whatever consultation is
required I defer to others and but it's
technically possible to do that I
presume
Huggins first and then maybe there was
something that you can respond to for
both of them
good morning I did raise this osc on on
Friday about the spurious nature of
saying that these timings to do with
Charity shop volunteering because there
are not that many charity shops within
um Stratford Town Center
um certainly those hours are not what
volunteers would necessarily uh work for
I mean this is you're talking such a
small proportion of residence and also I
really do question whether or not it is
the um
those are the older generation the over
65 so are in the greatest need of having
um some sort of concessionary car
parking scheme we were very uh cognizant
of the Manifest the manifesto pledges
you were making around this um but I do
feel that there are others in far
greater need those coming to work for
example that maybe in need need of these
um
need need of need of support and as far
as
the social ice social isolation there
have been many new initiatives you know
like the warm hubs and so forth and also
communities have have opened up far more
since uh the end of the uh covid covered
restrictions and also I question this
we're going to give them concessionally
you're proposing to give them
concessionary car parking but still I
have a cost of putting fuel in their
cars so they so the um the point about
raising money or saving them money is is
really uh not there because the
additional expenses will be there
actually using their motor vehicles so
I'm deeply uncomfortable about this
because I don't believe that it is
um that that this is for those in the
greatest need of parking concession I
believe that this is just solely to do
with the fact that you made a pledge in
your Manifesto about it thank you thank
you councilor wallow Huggins of course
this was a decision that was taken in
2021 and that was confirmed in March
2023 February March 2023 under your
Administration and I'm assuming that you
made all those points to the uh to your
your cabinet at that time uh thank you
very much councilor um Tony perks
uh thank you leader yeah I'm just really
picking up on the the debate before I
think we can technically we can do sort
of any hours that you want but I think
what's important is we decide what you
want to consult on so as we're we don't
get to the point where we sort of get
consultation responses back and have to
consult again and delay the initiative
so if you're minded to go for a wider
window then sort of nine to five I think
it would be worth giving us a steer here
and we can we can sort of or if you want
to consult on sort of acceptable hours
that's something we could do but I think
it would be useful to get a decision on
that rather so as we don't end up having
to come back with it
and capsular Rock
so presumably that's to do with how we
set out a consultation is it I mean we
can put a tick box in that says what
hours would people want uh rather than
saying if this or nothing we can ask
ask people in some construct
well-constructed way that question that
answers it without having to go back
again we can do that
okay
um chief executive sorry no I was just
interesting to know how Tony was going
to respond to that I might have
something
um yes we can we if you I'm looking for
a steer from cabinet if there are fixed
hours that you would like and there are
options of fixed hours we will consult
on sort of would you prefer this or this
or
it's a Fool's game sort of trying to
pretty good results for consultation but
if you say sort of what hours would you
like I suspect you'll get all hours back
it's unlikely anybody to convert so it's
it's really a steer of if you're happy
with all hours then say so but it's only
four hours within 24 is what you're
saying any four hours within 24 I think
is probably the easiest and simplest
thank you
yes I was just going to say that I agree
that should be only four hours between
any 24 hour period thank you
did you want to come in at that point
yeah I just want to come back on what
you said about the the March review we
we took away the parking permits because
we didn't see that the people the over
65s were necessarily those that were
benefiting the most
um so there were those one of the
greatest need and to do with uh
Financial property as well but the
question that I've got for you here is
when was this consultation actually done
and how long did it take to do it and
this the scoping of the consultation as
well because I'm concerned that given
the current set of circumstances and
financial services that people find
themselves in that this is that this is
out of date but I I didn't I didn't
really understand what your rebuttal to
me was about the decision made in March
23. thank you I would welcome your
Clarity clarification thank you because
uh I think the the question is uh were
those uh what were those options were
other options uh to give reduce parking
uh prices to other groups within the
society raised at that time and I think
they were not I can't I have two Ward
members would you like to come in at
this point
uh who's going to go first
hi
sorry
parking is among the most emotive issue
any Council has to deal with and the
last Administration took the view to
remove the retirement age permit and
charges for the and to charge the
fisherman's car park and these savings
had been built into the budget that
we've inherited so really we are
somewhat Limited in in what we can do
at that point as the chair pointed out
we were unaware of any other
opportunities to support to explore
um options to be consulted on
Kate and I and other councilors south of
the river have had a number of people
contacting us not just from town but
actually the districts out of the river
in response to to the closure of the
retirement uh time
they sorry
I'm pleased to see that we're actually
talking about
an offer to retirement and that is based
on bridgefoot and that is a good start
I do hope that the consultations has
been proposed will actually explore
other options for people south of the
river
which includes the district
because bringing cars across the bridge
and into the Town Center isn't a very
good idea when we're trying to actually
reduce that
I am actually point is pointed out to me
Often by people that all the other
Market towns in the district have
completely free parking for all age
ranges uh 24 7 30 every day of the year
and that's seen as an unfairness this
perhaps is a little offer towards the
town that they can actually Park more
reasonably in their time to access the
businesses and to support the Town
Central economy
thank you
councilor Ralph thank you
um in 2021 I put on record at cabinet
and for Council my resident's objections
to the withdrawal of the concessionary
permit by the previous administration
I'm pleased to see that our new
Administration is reconsidering the
whole parking permit policy and in
particular the reintroduction of the
concessionary pensioner's permit
as my fellow councilor gocot states
there will be further consultation on
concessionary parking permits but I feel
the need to reiterate my concerns about
the initial proposal put here in this
paper
before the conservatives withdrew the
permit they were approximately 2 400
permits issued since that point in
during during the recent election
campaign concessionary parking has
remained a notable talking point
I discovered that many of my residents
now shop in wellsborn lemington or even
Banbury and we need to get those people
back into using our town in the morning
in in the mornings for exercise walking
the dog using outdoor gym equipment in
the daytime for shopping
Etc and for charity workers and in the
evening for increasing and supporting
the nighttime economy
so whilst I work welcome the
introduction of a concessionary permit
I'm concerned by two of the terms and
conditions firstly that the maximum stay
of four hours between nine and five PM
only is too restrictive I would request
that this is altered to four hours
within a 24-hour period I would also
strongly recommend that when the take-up
numbers for the permit are reviewed in
the Autumn you will take into account
that many of mine Jenny's and Ian's
constituents south of the river and
further afield in the towns and Villages
are unlikely to use Bridgeway car park
in great numbers this is because of the
time restriction and the difficulty of
entering and exiting the car park of the
gyratory and the lack of a lift in a
multi-story car park with four flights
of stairs so I I would ask that the time
restriction condition be removed from
this initial concessionary permit and
replaced by four hours within a 24-hour
period this will increase the chance of
take-up and allow proper flexibility in
future consultation and policy thank you
thank you very much I I do hope that you
at the previous conversation does assure
you that that that is the intention
councilor crumper I've got your
to come on first
thank you um yeah this was was raised at
OSA quite a quite a good debate and we
even mentioned that one John didn't mean
counts the Gold Cup uh
I'm gonna guess this on so grow cup
um apologies yeah
we'll try and get it right we're trying
to get oversight and we'll get the
surnames right just about a second
um I think the issues
um
[Music]
I think it's down to a consultation the
consultation and work on this went back
to 2021 which is two years which is yeah
well over two years ago I think it was
spring 2021 and we all know that times
have moved on
um it's not the same place
and looking at the conversation that we
had osc and also today there just seem
to be some confusion and Clarity what is
best for the permits we've got two award
members here my writer who are not the
same party of me of course and they've
raised some reservations so I think the
issue we're trying to raise here
one hour using information it's aired to
date two is it brushed and three would
it been better to have all this
information ready before the scheme was
brought in so that that's just that's
one issue there
um so yeah we talked about local
consultation
we welcome the potential reciprocal
arrangement for the residents living in
the east
with Warwick so if that could be
explored and it was touched upon
um because I know the residents in the
East you know from South and they won't
come over 23 24
um miles uh 40 mile round trip to come
for four hours at um at Stratford they
just won't do that
um so I think that would be welcome
um we're also welcome that any review
takes place to promptly as ever uh data
provided on the areas where these
permits are purchased from to see
whether they are mainly Stratford Town
Centric or within a few miles so just to
see where people are coming from
the point was raised about
um the scheme might not be
the most fine benefits in the most
financially in need and perhaps other
residents such as families with the
young children
might be some of the hardest hit during
the cost of living crisis so again I
think we need to take that into account
as well
um again we're concerned about active
travel
um which the deputy of
the deputy chairman oversea raised
um
and again it was just I think case the
rock writers it was the issue about the
nighttime economy as well and again I
think that needs to be looked at you
know uh and and the gap between the free
park and after six on on Street compared
to paying for parking off street at the
time so in that Gap as well so I think
lots of issues to be considered
is this the right scheme
we it's got flaws in um um so
we think perhaps it might have been
better consultation or proper
um seems slightly rushed
um so
I think would as a council would rather
get things right first time rather than
having to keep amending them so that
might be something we need to learn uh
and yeah make sure our consultation is
up to date and the data
um is available is the best as well so
Council Rock
counselor uh
thank you Jenny fragie come in first
thank you I was just going to make a
comment about the consultation
somebody's I think it was said that it
would be completed by the end of August
beginning of September
um I'm concerned that's the holiday
period and a lot of people will be away
perhaps we could consider the end date
of the consultation to make sure we
include as many peoples as possible
thank you councilor Rock
thank you chair
um apart from issues on consultation and
technically how that's done to which I
deferred to others I made a couple of
proposals one that I'm one two one we
just cross out between the hours of
because that latter part of the the
sentence will then leave it open and
that consultation can be constructed
accordingly and and I want I would like
to add I think um uh as counselor Crump
has just said that there's a clear
request to officers to explore with
Warwick if they are minded to engage
with us about a reciprocal Arrangement
and what the possibilities are so that's
that's a question that we should ask
them
so I'll make those two proposals
chairman but otherwise I'm I'm happy
happy to see the consultation along the
lines has been discussed happy to
um accept those proposals councilor girl
come okay I think this has been an
extremely good um debate and this is
what I I actually appreciate um from
cabinet that we are we are having
um a proper debate and and really do
appreciate the input from everybody it
has been beneficial uh from that point
of view
um just one comment further and that is
that apart from this uh totally separate
from this we do need to look and work
with the County Council on uh on
transport strategy because that's been
one thing that has been lacking for a
long long time across Stratford uh we
lost the park and ride on the south side
for example but uh Birmingham road is a
problem the park and ride on the North
side's a problem uh we do need to get
that sorted and I would ask that County
councilors uh and and officers speak to
the County Council about making sure
that our transport strategy is fit for
purpose across the whole town as well
but that's for another day so now I do
have a record a recommendation
um that a concessionary permit out as
outlined in this report and as amended
be agreed and can I have a proposal for
that and then a second and then we can
go to the vote on that
I could post that and do we have a
second
counselor capture
and then we go to the vote on this one
are you happy that we go out to the
consultation as amended uh and thank you
very much for your vote
that's agreed unanimously thank you
and the next item also counts as
counselor grow cuts
um it's off street parking places order
strategy consultation and this is about
to consider the comments another
representative representations received
from the off street parking places order
statutory consultation councilor Goku
thank you chair yes this is off street
parking places order which was going to
be implemented in August 2023 so we've
had the results back from the
consultation
the background was that we were going to
be
um in 2021
um they were going to Evolution the over
65s permit introducing charging in
Fisherman's car park and increasing
hourly tariffs at the Leisure Center for
the car parks of the lorries
coaches in motorhomes and increase
overnight charges at Stratford Leisure
Center
so this has gone out for 21 day
consultation and most of the comments
that we have had back for the off street
parking places orders has actually
concerned the introduction of charges to
the fisherman's car park I mean
obviously this has been a place of
traditionally used for free for people
using fishermen of Anglers for people
partaking in water sports like open
swimming and canoeing so we were very
sensitive to the considerations of this
group
so most of the feedback we have got an
appendix one is to do with the people
who are using it mainly for those
activities there has been no other
feedback from the
um area to do with the increase in a
chart car parking charges apart from one
which was which we've just lost
um okay thank you oh very gentlemanly
um which is actually to do with the um
Carriage Pat it's Town Council from
um shipston
um which was the telegraph Street Car
Park which is it was formally free
um to Residents sorry it was formerly
there was a charge on it but sorry okay
very small charge okay
um and it's just going up from
um 20p to 40p for one hour
um the parish council has
um Town Council has raised some
objections to those can I bring in a
David Buckland the chief executive at
that point because he has an update yeah
thank you chairman just to confirm on
the members uh desk this off this
morning even sorry we'll meet you in the
morning now
um is is the correspondence from ships
and Town Council who did raise concerns
about the increase in in charges at
Telegraph street and and this is the
only car park outside of Stratford upon
Haven where we do make charges so so
going back to the previous item there is
a car park we do charge it's increased
seeking to increase from 20p to 40p an
hour generally although no chair changes
to the permits which are on the site
there's two different types of residence
permits and there's a special scheme
that we have in place they introduced
probably about five years ago in
relation to the old Bakery in in
shipston as well there was comments were
received after the consultation period
form we ended but we did Endeavor in the
spirit of openness and transparency to
raise their concerns with the Covenant
this morning and they're they're on your
desks thank you
and and again this was one of the ones
that was
um something that had happened in the
past and um but it has come true one
thing one reason why it has come to us
is because also we when we looked at a
particular one particular car park which
is the fisherman's car park
um it was considered by other people
some of the responses but I also
considered it that using just a Ringo
app was not um the best practice
um because it can be considered
discriminatory to those people who do
not have modern mobile phones so
improvements were considered and one of
those improvements was to make sure that
there were other ways of payment
um being made available but they the
original decision was taken in 2021 and
confirmed in
2023 to come in in first of August 2023.
uh have I got councilor go want to take
that further
and yet of course and to say most of the
additional feedback there's been for the
users of Lynch Meadow where there has
been a conversation in the past the town
trust and District trust that um people
that were using the meadow were
concerned that um you know this would be
detrimental to people coming along and
using it for dog walking and that sort
of that sort of activity so we have made
Provisions with things like bins and
that sort of stuff to make sure that the
um it is kept as pleasant as possible
for the users councilor capture
can I just uh come bring us back to the
shipston situation because clearly
obviously this is a this is a a quite
different I think Arrangement which we
have in ships and I understand that it's
not necessarily that we have charges
there for raising uh money but we're
there to make sure that the the the
parking space is turned over at a
regular basis it does seem a little
heavy to actually double the charge from
20p to to 40p and I wonder whether if
it's not a financial
um consideration if we perhaps reduce
that to say uh proposal of 20 to 30p
um which would be I think more
reasonable
I cancel away hug and she won't come in
at that point
yes I could comment on the ships and
charging because I live in shipston
um 20 pence is as attractive sum of
money
um I think uh because it gets people in
and out of the car Parks quickly that's
that's this parking is very limited
however that's not actually the reason I
wanted to talk today can I raise the
point in um the background information
here that we raise about
um just to give you a little bit of
background information
um one of my
uh registered interest is that my
husband owns a road haulage company to
do with fuels but also
and I used to be an hgv Lorry driver
trainer I know shot car or whoever knew
that about me however I would like to
raise the 1000 increase in charges for
lorries particularly in the Stratford
Leisure Center car park from two pounds
to 20 pounds can somebody explain to me
from this Administration just I just can
I just carry on there is there is a
reason for the question
I was just wondering whether because
you've declared an interest because of
your husband having a a haulage firm
that that was something that was
actually a pecuniary interest
foreign
probably would be something that you'd
have to declare
um
you I I take the point that you're not
actually making the decision but there's
still the influence that you might have
over the decision
um
okay I'll withdraw the question and I'm
going to hand this over to Andy Andy
crumb
counselor Crump a
on the assumption that you're not going
to raise a particular haulage issue
which is a direct
peculiar interest from from your fellow
counselor
no mine will be a more General Point
um I think the issue is that
um
it mentions motor homes as well and
obviously people with motor homes are
usually coming to
spend some money in in the in the town
uh adds to our
Angela Crump can I just raise this this
was again something that was resolved in
2021 and confirmed in February 2023
under your Administration and you're
raising these issues now uh you could
have actually raised them with the
administration which was your
administration at that time can I just
add on to them please
um it's the fact that you've reviewed
you're reviewing the car park
um for the concessions
um but it's not been wise to review that
at the same time as we're looking to
encourage people to come into town
um such as Elton John
um to spend some time here and obviously
motorhomes of people are touring around
the area so I would not only necessarily
spending money in the town and also be
spending money in the other Market towns
as well so it's just important and could
I just say the statutory consultation
did take place did you actually come
submit those thoughts to that statutory
consultation
no because that's not relevant because
what we're saying is what I'm trying to
say here is that you've reviewed one of
the policies that was in place for 20
started in 21 has been brought in place
in 2023 as in the the concessionary
permit for the over 60s over 65s
was this considered at the same time are
they not an equal priority
thank you
Tony perks do you want to come in
um yes it might help the cabinet if I
just gave a little background to why the
charges were considered on the large and
the motorhomes um it's not for me to
have a view on it but
um we have over probably the last sort
of five years started to see a increase
in sort of motorhome sort of using sort
of the back of the Leisure Center as a
campsite and sort of parking overnight
and sort of taking the holidays in the
Leisure Center car park which the
previous administration took the view
wasn't really what it was there for
um it was um whilst we'd support sort of
the motorhomes were coming to Stratford
for the day we didn't really want them
stopping over so the the increase in the
night's charge was to um try and
dissuade people from that and get them
to move on to the camera sites available
around the area the issue with the
lorries was there was a theory at least
that lorries were being drawn down from
the M40 where it cost significantly more
to stop over and we're actually sort of
coming in and overnight staying in
Stratford because it was so cheap and
that was causing some angst to the
neighbor bring residents who raised that
so I believe that the charge there was
um introduced in response to those
issues I just thought it might be useful
background for you
thank you but that's very very useful so
this was this is to be clear this is the
overnight charge
um the not to the daytime charge so
thank you very much indeed for that it's
really good clarification
I have a a recommendation to put to you
and that is that the following that
following the completion of the off
street parking places order statutory
consultation which has already been
completed uh the proposed charges at
Fisherman's car park and their
inflationary creases at the other car
parks are agreed and implemented in full
from the 1st of August
2023 councilor counter
I would like to amend that in relation
to ships than the shipston charge is
reduced from the doubling of charges to
just an additional 10 pence a an hour
so that's at the top the uh the the
um do we have an officer's um
if I may that's okay
um
charges uh Telegraph street haven't been
increased for at least 15 years nearer
20 years if you look at inflationary
increases since 2003
then the actual amount would equate to
20 pence in 2003 is the equivalent of
41.4 Pence now
so it's nearer to 40 Pence than 30 P if
the rate of inflation increase have been
applied for the last 20 years
anybody got um
do you want to come back on that yes I
mean I mean I think
I I think just because this Council has
been negligent and not actually Rising
it for such a long period of time is not
a reason for whacking up the charge now
I think doubling the charge will be a
motive in shipston I think I I would be
if I was living in ships and I would be
very concerned about that
um I think a more stepped Arrangement
should be better and I would propose
that the increase should be
substantially less than that and only 10
pence an hour
so that is for the up to one hour should
be 20 from 20 pence to it should be 30
Pence rather than 40 Pence have we got a
secondary for that
chairman can I just be clear about the
other charges and if so if you're
looking at the one hour charge reducing
that from 40 Pence to 30 Pence
I assume that the next increase of the
up to two hours which is going from 40
Pence
to 60 Pence maybe I suggest take that to
50p but then leave the the other bands
actually unchanged because the
percentage increases on the others are
much less significant than that one hour
and two hour charges
I think that will be acceptable yeah
okay
um
do you want to propose that one who's
going to would second that one
counter go cup okay so with that
that is now to be put to the uh as
amended the recommendation is that as
amended following the completion
um of the off street parking places or
the strategy consultation the proposed
charges at Fisherman's car park and the
increases it inflationary increases at
other car parks are agreed and
implemented in full from the 1st of
August 2023 and we've taken into
consideration
um the response by shipston Town Council
in that regard thank you and are we
going to put that to the vote now those
in favor
and anybody against
thank you
the next item is the future use of
Elizabeth house and that comes under uh
councilor Rock
uh thank you chairman
um
those of us that are familiar with the
uh with the building
I hesitate to say
familiar because I'm sure new councilors
can't find their way around the maze
that is this building but we'll be aware
that there are very large areas that are
vacant unused and there's clearly an
opportunity
um
the work that's been done so far is that
we we should let it on a fully
commercial basis uh to a client that's
interested and that client is in fact um
a case over the road
and
there's a lot of details to be worked
out not most and I have a particular
interest in making sure that the
corporate identity of the council is
preserved um though so there's going to
be quite a lot of design work that's
involved in making that available and
we've got this sort of portico entrance
here and we're going to try and work
something out there but the the
principles are are all expressed in the
report
um councilors will will be aware that
there is a an exempt uh appendix to this
which if we need to discuss that we'll
have to go into confidential session
afterwards
um but uh I I recommend this on the to
the cabinet as the way forward I set out
in the report thank you chairman and do
we have any other comments to make on
that are any questions counselor Crump
thank you um this was debated at OSU and
we felt it was a fair and reasonable
paper and a a pragmatic solution to to
the usage of the spice at Elizabeth
house uh the only thing we wanted to add
on to it and I think um one of the local
board members
it was not here now
um raised a point about road safety and
the crossing and and parking uh if it's
going to be used by the the
the demograph that it's proposed trying
to be as subtle as possible there
um there might be Road Safety
considerations that that could be be
looked into such as parking regulations
Etc that was that was just the only
thing otherwise we were happy with the
report at MSC
um Tony first do you want to come in at
this time uh yes sir I think that that
comment did come up with the ovian
shooting commission and I think it's a
fair issue to raise the quite a lot of
detail to work if if this is supported
by the camera today and we sort of move
it forward there are a number of issues
to resolve I'll pick that up with the
school and the highways Authority is
part of that process
and we just need to make it clear that
as I understand it there is already a 20
mile per hour speed limit on that road
but we need to get that clarification
clarified and it'll be part of the
process in talking to the school
so we have a recommendation that the
subletting of Elizabeth House in line
with the heads of terms set out in
exempt appendix one be agreed and that
the deputy chief executive in
consultation with the leader of the
council be authorized to negotiate and
agree detailed terms are you happy with
that and you could I'm happy to propose
that is there anybody who's willing to
second that for me
councilor Rock and is there that go to
the vote on that one
those are in a favor
that is unanimous
happy with that thank you moving
next item is the draft Revenue out turn
report for 2022 2023 and we go to the
counselor David Curtis for this thank
you thank you chair
um purpose of this report is provide
members with the revenue outcome
position for the year ended 31st March
2023 and to note the allocation of
funding to earmark Reserves
firstly I'd like to thank section 151
officer Richard Burrell for his patience
and um the preparing such a
comprehensive report and the appendices
so the report comes with three
recommendations which you can see in
front of you the draft 2022 23 out turn
figures and the explanation of variance
be noted the favorable variance of 1.2
million is added to the general fund
Revenue balances
and the amount allocated the amount
reserves be noted
um I'd just like to draw cabinet's
attention to 1.3 in particular the
actual out turn position of a favorable
1.2 mid one million 238 1484 pounds an
improvement of one
684 over the amount reported in the
March budget monitoring report and this
is after 500 000 pounds has been added
to the earmarked inflation Reserve
this Edition is largely attributable to
the additional interest received on
investments
the earmarked inflation Reserve is now
1.5 million which you can see in
appendix 4 Page 56.
and although this may seem high
given current inflation and volatility
in the sector I agree with Section 151
officer that this is a prudent measure
however as certainty returns some of
this Reserve may be released to help
fund some of our policy priorities
so I asked cabinet to agree that the
favorable variance of 1 million 238 184
pounds is added to the general fund
balances and when we carry out a budget
review over the next six months and as
part of the budget setting process that
will commence in September for 24.25 we
can realign our budgets and reserves to
meet our policy priority priorities
so I the report comes with the three
recommendations
um happy to take any questions on that
yes it's just a question for you
councilor Curtis
um at the end of the last Labor
government Liam Byrne left a note saying
there was no money left I was just
wondering if counselor Harvey left a
note for you to saying uh
um that there was plenty of money left
and trying to be on due to our prudent
leadership there was money available and
that he hoped that you would be spending
Stratford taxpayers money wisely thank
you
thank you very much for that question
Cyril Council of Wally hoggins um yes I
do I do recall that that comment
um and clearly yes currently
the district council's funds appear to
be in a relatively strong position
and
it is important that we use those
resources wisely as I'm sure everyone
sitting around this table would agree
of course we are subject to the vagaries
of central government and of course
until we have longer term financial
planning from central government we will
have to be extremely prudent but yes we
are in a far better position than some
local authorities at the moment and I
assure almost present that we will make
very careful use of those resources but
it is important that those resources are
used to meet our political priorities
but thank you for the question councilor
councilor rock thank you
um
I just wanted to ask probably a question
for uh Richard Burrell here but I'll
just respond to that the purpose of the
council is not to hold taxpayers money
as some sort of bank it's there to
deliver services for residents and
that's what the the money should be used
for albeit we're not in the situation
that the labor government was in leaving
notes behind
um but getting back to the
um
the
reserves that are occurring as a result
of inflationary
benefits as far as insurance as far as
interest rates are concerned
are we going to have some rational uh
I'm not just gonna say rational but a
mechanistic approach to what happens
with interest rates and therefore when
we
decide to release the the this 500 000
pounds
because things are going a different
direction I mean is there a sort of
analytical process that will result in
it or we'll just be judgment on what we
think
what is going to happen to markets
actually if we all knew what was going
to happen to markets we'd all be
millionaires wouldn't we but
um you know is there going to be a way
of looking at a formula or something
like that that we decide when we're
going to how much of this to deal with
and and when
um thank you very much for that Council
Rock
um it is very difficult and as you say I
think if we could if any of us could
predict markets we'd probably be sitting
on our own Caribbean islands rather than
sitting around well no I'm sure we'd all
prefer to be here rather than I don't
know
um
I have asked Richard to prepare a cash
flow for the next year of the reserves
that would allow us to possibly predict
um what interest what what income there
may be from interest but it is very
volatile it is very difficult but
Richard can I hand it to you if you can
go for further detail yes thank you uh
thank you councilor curses yeah the the
one and a half million is to cover
unbudgeted inflationary effects um when
we prepared the budget last year I put
in about four percent for the majority
of the inflation purely because the
predictions then said that inflation
wouldn't be hanging around at the
current higher level as it currently is
so
as soon as inflation tells down in
interest rates similarly follow down
that one and a half million can be
released so it's a judgment call really
on there's a judgment on how the economy
is and how how stable we see that going
forward and until
price is stabilize that I would like to
keep that some to in an ear might
Reserve to meet any unexpected
cost increases I think we think we had
councilor Crum did you want to come in
at this stage
thank you chairman yeah just brief I
will discuss in a bit more on General
points in the update from oversea there
was one specific point which I sort of
tentatively raised I think on Friday
with councilor Curtis I ran car parking
the car parking short four is around
about 390 000 which is quite significant
and if you look in conjunction with
um 12 the revenue budget monitoring for
23.24 it seems to be a 60k shortfall
already in two months which again is
quite significant so I think
um when
uh when we're looking at the car park
and obviously we're looking at the
permits I think there's a whole raft of
work there to do with uh park car
parking in in Stratford District because
it's a significant income driver and
that's no pun intended on this occasion
councilor Curtis
um but um yeah it can form a part of the
basis so I think
something needs to be done to ensure
um this income income levels are
maintained otherwise there could be a
significant Gap in the council finances
um you know so it's just just a comment
for cancer Curtis to see
um I assume they're working with
councilor golcat on on that to ensure
that income levels are maintained as
much as possible I'll bring councilor
Curtis back in again
thank you
um thank you Council to come for that uh
comment if you like
um
when the parking perk just two separate
points there I think you've made one is
around the potential loss of income by
introducing or reintroducing the
concessionary parking permits
please yeah it's just the fact that
that is one small part of the whole
process so
you could say it's tinkering around the
edges whereas there might be a major
level of work area of work to ensure
this significant short for
particularly I would assume rent season
tickets maybe needs to be looked at or
something needs to be revised around
that
thank you um
Richard did you have particular comments
thinking yeah if I could come in on that
Council of curses the 2223 budget was
put together in 20 at the end of 21. we
were just coming out of covid and we
have seen a shift in the way people are
parking we saw a downturn in the parking
permits and I think that's due to people
home working so the quarterly permit
that people were buying significantly
dropped off because people weren't
committing to buying that permit to put
in their car
um so so the budget for the current
Financial year was adjusted last year
and we've had an extremely wet start to
the season uh you know we've had three
bank holidays and we are a tourist
destination and do rely on good weather
to achieve
our income targets when it comes to
parking so I would say it's not
surprising but slightly disappointing
that it is down but that's the reason
I mean one other things that we need to
look at going forward uh is and it's not
for today's debate but uh it's just the
way high streets are like I mean but
also our economic strategy which is
underdevelopment at the moment
um moving on then we do have the
recommendation to this report which has
already been outlined by councilor
Curtis but the recommendations are three
and that is that the draft 2022-23 out
turn figures and the explanation of
variance has been noted
that the favorable variance of 1.238 and
184 is added to the general fund Revenue
balances and the amounts allocated to
the earmarked reserves be noted and
could I have a somebody who will propose
that please councilor Curtis and
somebody who's seconded councilor Coles
and can we have a vote as to whether to
accept that recommendation
okay I'm happy with that thank you that
was unanimous
and then moving on which is another item
for councilor Curtis which is the um
draft Capital out to the capital out
term for 2022-23 under Capital slippage
which is on pages 57 to 78 of your
papers councilor Curtis
thank you Jeff
um so the purpose of this report is to
provide the cabinet with details of the
capital out in 2022-23 and again at
first I'd like to thank Nicola Reynolds
for her
um the very comprehensive report and
dependencies
you have the recommendations in front of
you
um there are some significant slippage
items and the most significant of these
slippage items and amended budgets are
detailed on page 58 to 60 of the report
and they are recorded in Greater detail
in appendix 3.
some concern was raised at overview and
scrutiny on Friday about slippage and
any additional costs or delays that the
council May incur as a result of any
slippage and I think it might be helpful
for all of us I'm just going to ask
Richard Barrell to give an outline of
the key items in that slippage the most
significant items but also Richard
perhaps if you could give us a very
short briefing on what slippage actually
is and the implications thank you
yes thank you councilor Curtis yes
slippage isn't a bad thing when it comes
to Capital schemes Capital schemes by
their nature are well they tend to be
schemes that extend over one year unlike
the revenue budget
so the list that is explained on
appendix 3 contains things such as the
materials recycling facility that the
councils
contributing to Wars and that's spread
over a number of years when we budget
for Capital works we budget right at the
beginning for the full amount so if
something extends over three years that
amount has slipped forward to meet the
future expenditure
so rather than slip as you could you
could call it phased budgeting as well
but we've traditionally always called it
uh slippage the big figures within there
like I say is the materials recycling
facility that's about one and a half
million we've got about four and a half
million in there to meet the cost of our
refuse vehicles and a large amount of
section 106 and still managed over 3
million so that's that's money that
we're holding that we will be issuing
so it's not a case that schemes aren't
being completed that we will incur costs
as a result it's just the phasing of
that money leaving the authority
do we have any questions from counselors
before that to the portfolio holder or
to the officer
councilor Crump
thank you chairman um
I think the main issue regard them is
two things twofold really
um one uh councilor Rock said you know
raised the point earlier about not
keeping money so we can invest it for
longer
um
and we need to spend the money wisely
efficiently effectively which is which
is fine
um I think there needs to be we found
osc there needs to be some explanation
about Capital Works a member's briefing
to as as Mr burrow said you know well
there's some explanation of phase
budgeting what is general uh genuine
slippage
because I will slightly disagree with
him that slippage can be detrimental I
mean when you've got 10 inflation a
scheme that was supposed to be completed
in year X is then completed two years
then the line
with 10 inflation on those 30 years
you're either gonna have to pay extra
money for it or you will provide this so
I think this needs to be some clarity
around that
um
and we follow the members briefing
particularly ran the bigger screens that
come around the country such as Wells
airport uh the wells-bourne SPD for
University campus Etc would be good so
people understand these figures because
when you look at the figures firsthand
you would see that slippage into 23 24
is 10 times the original budget we've
had some explanation about that and and
that is fine but it does seem to be some
crack needs to be some clarity what a
genuine slippage what is five slippage
or phase budgeting and also the impact
on those Capital schemes whether they
will be subject to significant inflation
and what that means in terms of extra
resources for that Capital scheme or
they'll be re-engineered to provide
something less
Council coaches
I think oh
sorry my I seem to oh no I'm still there
aren't I sorry
thank you councilor Crum I absolutely
share your concerns that any unintended
or unplanned slippage we should be
mindful that
that could potentially lead to
additional costs with inflation but I I
think and I think it is something that
going forward this Administration will
should have every intention of
monitoring our capital projects perhaps
more carefully than has been done in the
past so I welcome that suggestion
um but I am reassured by Mr Burrell that
the the very large proportion of this
slippage is is actually planned so
Richard if you have any further comment
to add
thank you Council because yeah certainly
the larger figures like the materials
recycling facility when we put 20 this
Current financial Year's budget together
we were aware of the additional costs
relating to that scheme and that's been
built in a lot of that related to the
Canadian dollar exchange rate and there
were inflationary pressures so that's
that's in there and that's
Incorporated
um the refuse vehicles have been
purchased by Warwick District Council
and that sum there is for us they're
currently in internally financing those
vehicles and that Sun's there
for us to purchase back those Vehicles
when the time's right so those vehicles
have been bought so there's no
inflationary effects there and all the
section 106 and seal money are
allocations then they're not something
that's being built that could be subject
to inflation the smaller amounts at the
top yes I quite agree where we're
installing some networking and servers
and firewalls but they're relatively
small amounts and uh
to a degree that's where the um earmark
Reserve I referred to earlier on the one
and a half million could come into play
if they significantly overspent
but I I don't have any concerns that
inflation will
significantly alter this
Capital program
thank you very much indeed yeah
just I think it's important the the
comment that Mr Martin has just made
there that we have this additional
inflation Reserve in case there is
unforeseen additional inflation but
thank you very much for that thank you
very much indeed has anybody else got
any questions that they want to raise
otherwise I will ask for a proposal and
secondary to the recommendation that the
capital budget for 2023 24 be increased
by
173 11 million 173
773. yes it's I'm not used to dealing
with Millions no as detailed in appendix
one in 2022-23 for slippage listed in
appendix 3 financed by the capital
receipts as budgeted for in 2022-23.
um do I have a proposal did councilor
Curtis and a seconder
thank you very much indeed and put that
to the vote are you all happy
yeah
thank you very much and moving on to the
next item which is also councilor Curtis
which is the annual treasury management
review
2022-23 and that's to consider the
annual treasury management review of
activities for the year thank you thank
you very much chair gosh right
um again like to thank the office of
cases of Sylvester in this case for
preparing this comprehensive report and
appendices you see the recommendations
in front of you I would just
particularly like cabinet to note points
1.3 and 1.4 which gives a clear outline
of the responsibilities on cabinet
notice just like to draw our attention
to that
um members will be aware of the most
recent treasury training slides training
sessions I'm sorry given by link Asset
Services direct and nazmin Mir which was
given on the 14th of June those slides
are available for anybody who missed
Miss missed this session
um and has been also briefed the cash
management working group which I chair
on Tuesday the 20th of June
um
page 95 there is an evidence based the
10.1 the council employs the services of
Link Asset Services areas that advises
on Treasury management and the
investment matters
the issue interest rate forecasts and
advises on Treasury management practices
and procedures based on its wider
expertise in the public sector
happy to take any questions
thank you
any questions
I can say no questions so I will put
that straight to the recommendation
um that the actual
treasury actual 2023 to 23 prediction
and treasury indicators in this report
are approved and that the annual
treasury management report be received
proposal
counselor Curtis and seconder
councilor broker
anybody have any other opinions no in
that case I put it to the vote
those are proving thank you
moving on to the next item it is also
councilor Curtis and this is the capital
budget monitoring yes the council the
court is shown thank you chair this is
my final appearance I hope that this uh
you've got one more
oh Lord
oh yes
right here
apologies chair so
um you have the detail of what this
report contains
um again another excellent report an
appendices provided by Nicola Reynolds
we have the recommendations in front of
you
um just picking up points that were
raised earlier by councilor Crump and I
believe Council of Wally hoggins
that we do need to be assured that work
continues in The Current financial year
to ensure as many projects are as
possible are delivered within their time
scales and that the progress is is
carefully monitored this report also
contains the slippage previously
referred to in the capital outturn
report
and one other thing I just mentioned to
to Cabinet is that in appendix 2
um
not necessarily for discussion today but
in appendix to Cabinet might like to
note the proportion of section 106
funding that is committed to off-site
affordable housing so I just mentioned
that as perhaps something for us to
consider in future thank you chair and
thank you for raising that one because
um that is one of the issues that has
affected my ward
um that use of
monies that have been then used off-site
to provide affordable housing not in the
board that I I represent so it's
something that I would like it further
explain our exploration on but that's
for another day and for another officer
um but um we we now have
um a recommendation in for in front of
us anybody want to raise any particular
questions before I move to the
recommendation
in that case I move the recommendation
uh that the position on capital
expenditure and income for the period
one to two of 20 23 24 is received and
any issues identified for further
consideration to be addressed by a
further report to the cabinet and the
portfolio holder now I do have a
proposal for that one councilor Curtis
and a seconder councilor guest okay
thank you very much indeed and that one
now goes to the vote are you happy for
that to be approved
yes that's all unanimous thank you very
much indeed and moving and moving on to
the final councilor Curtis report which
is the revenue budget mandatory
thank you chair
you have the summary in front of you
um I'd like to thank Jessica Leo for
preparing this report on appendices and
Jessica is a very new to this Council
and you will see on page 123 the
earmarked reserves I'm sure you've all
noticed this are in alphabetical order
which I have thanked Jessica for taking
this initiative it may make comparing
the current papers with previous harder
but I do think going forward having
these appendices and the earmarked
reserves and so forth in alphabetical
order will make it much easier for
members and members of the public who
I'm sure are riveted by these favors to
find their way around so I think that
it's a small initiative but I think it
it is actually very very helpful
um
not much to say on this um point you may
like to know the um
estimated outturn
the a couple of points here really four
one two
draw attention to these
um
off-street parking we've already
discussed the refuse collection under
unfair unfavorable variance I do
apologize of 480 000
um I've had a breakdown of costs uh from
Mr Barrow on that the additional costs
following the Eddington fire were 120
000 pounds
um contractual Arrangements means some
of these additional costs will be shared
um and there'll be greater Clarity on
what the council can expect reported in
the net next budget monitoring report
waste collections from increased number
of properties is the balance of 280 000.
this will be offset by additional
council tax collected in the longer term
but in
2023-24 these costs remain over budget
so the recommendation is the actual neck
variants
as a period two and the estimated
revenue outturn for 2023-24 be received
thank you chair and are you proposing
that recommendation yes I will unless
there are any questions unless there's
any questions are there any questions to
cancel a rock
uh thank you chair
um I
perhaps it's for a future meeting but
you the points that you made about the
ettington fire
um I'm just wondering if it's apart from
more further down the table here but are
there some learning points from that
because we've basically privatized the
uh
the processing at pure recycling at
ettington
um then there's a fire
there's Insurance involved a complicated
sure I'm sure complicated set of
exchanges about insurance and who's
liable for what
that's all sort of historical and I'm
sure is being dealt with
administratively but any new
Arrangements that we have for anything
that's outsourced
we do want to make sure that we're not
just privatizing the profits and not
privatizing the risks so
um I'm just wondering if there's any
learning points to be talked about in
some other form possibly
perhaps that's some counselor girl can't
do you want to raise that and answer
that one I mean obviously obviously May
correct me here but I think part of the
um Outlook was the unique position of
the um the Murph coming online uh next
month and the fact was we couldn't take
any long the obviously the fire was an
unexpected development of course but it
was the fact that we were like in very
short-term contracts just because of the
um the Merv coming online which will
actually
accommodate our Recycling and of course
once that they um we do have the
manufacture you know Sherborne
operational that takes that whole risk
out of our things there's a lot of fire
prevention there I've been and had a
look
thank you so we do have a recommendation
before us and it uh councilor Curtis
you've proposed that I believe
um do we have a second of that term
counselor
thank you very much indeed should we go
to the vote on that one happy for you
too
support that one and that again is
unanimous thank you very much indeed
before we move on to the next item I
would like to just say something very
special and that is that I would like to
welcome a new officer head of Housing
and customer services and that is
Annette Homer who is in on her first day
today uh to this District Council uh
really would welcome you to this
District Council uh just before we move
on to the housing and customer services
portfolio reports so thank you very much
for joining us here today and I look
forward to working with you for many
many years to come thank you
and then next we move on to the housing
strategy action update which is the
portfolio of counselor course
sorry leader it's probably a a a with
wrong footage you slightly
um because this actually sits within the
policy unit which is
the culture my apologies though it's to
do with housing strategy it is the camp
it is the area of counselor capture of
rest assured councilor Coles and myself
are working very closely together
um in relation to head to housing going
forward this report clearly is relating
to the previous administration
um on a plan produced by the previous
administration
um which goes forward till uh 2026.
I think it is a report that we can note
at this point in time however certainly
with Annette Homer coming on board
um we will be looking to substantially
review where we go in relation to this
strategy in the future we want to make
sure that housing in this district is
demand lead and not developer driven
which is where we've been in the past
and I think we need to see a much
greater emphasis on zero carbon housing
in in this District as well so I suspect
they will be reflected in future reviews
of this strategy but for this point in
time this is a a report really noting
what has happened up until the 30th of
April
culture and I do note that
um we and now that we've got a new
officer and now that remember the new
ministry we do have quite a lot of plans
and ideas that we want to explore and we
talk both Council both departments and
we look forward to that so the
recommendations are that the report be
noted and that the revised action plan
in this report be agreed and councilor
Couture are you planning to put a
propose that one and move those
recommendations yeah and councilor Coles
do you want to second that one thank you
uh and uh on the vote
happy for that to go forward thank you
we now have part C which is issues
arising from overview and scrutiny
committee uh and that is councilor Crump
hopefully quite brief because we've
discussed quite a few of those
um one thing I did forget to mention was
about the wells born SBD for the
University campus uh the other thing we
requested or we asked is that um local
residents
can be seen to benefit
from any development because we don't
know having all the pain in no gain and
I think the portfolio holder took that
on board and it was also
um we did mention about the gap between
the campus and chocolate and then
obviously the gap between the campus and
was born and we did have two members of
from the wells born area on at the
meeting so I think that was taken on
board so again I think that was a fair
and reasonable report we touched on
about Elizabeth house again we've got no
real issues about that and the concern
was about Road Safety
Parkin's gave me right going on around
so give accounts a gray cutter a brief
respite there uh we talked about Capital
net and revenue budgets the other thing
that was more a general Point rather
than you know we could mention
specifically as part of the full cabinet
is
um the issue of staff and vacancies
um and again it suggested that some of
the favorable variances might be in part
of this you know when we could perhaps
ask the the cabinet to consider to have
a career in local government could be
made more attractive uh to be to school
than younger people
um and obviously with any vacancies
there's the potential to impact on
customer service and maybe the reason
for some of the reasons why projects
have stepped if we've got nobody
managing those
um Quality Recruitment and Retention is
vital obviously several key staff left
recently taken significant knowledge
with them
um acknowledged that the council is in a
period of transition with with people
starting today
Annette and this needs to be property
managed so I think that's that's a
concern that you know we've got to make
sure that we've got the right staff
we've got the task and finish group
working party sorted out
um to do with houses associations and
we're trying to keep it narrowly focused
on contact and Repair Service
um is the feedback from the scrutiny
officers research in the housing and
customer service seriously these were
mainly the main reasons for the
complaints
you can go into this task and finish
group could be really wide you know you
go into one thing yeah exactly and that
might be for future working groups but
we're really going to concentrate on
that area
um and and try as best to come we've got
the working party of five and we've got
yourself and councilor Keithley who will
be willing to make contributions to to
the group uh we've had a member of
public volunteer and he was actually at
osc so we'll get things from from the
residence point of viewpoint as well
um but yeah that's particularly an area
of concern and finally
uh we talked about Capital One Revenue
uh the work plan
um obviously we've been able to give
portfolio how there's some leeway to get
used to their uh portfolio so they're
going to be starting from
Cabinet member Christian times have been
from September with yourself on the
first of September I believe followed by
Council The Rock on the 29th of
September so start start off with a
double whammy and then we're also having
Shakespeare's England in and the
indicated integrated care board as well
at the next meeting
um we really think that there are two
areas that we need to to get a grip on
um they might be long meetings so if you
are come to those ones make sure you've
got your sandwiches your your cocoa and
anything else to keep you awake because
we feel that it's vital to get them in
and one of the partners that was the
only time they're viable so uh General
points and we're actually completing the
meetings within the time just over two
and a half hours the last two so
um that's been quite good but I think
the next one might be double that so
just think just about that in mind so
when you come to the next meeting
so thank you for that I'll send that the
minutes to you as well yeah thank you
very much indeed I I do like um the I I
think the work uh using working groups
is very productive way of of using uh
councilor and other people's time uh and
certainly I've I've already volunteered
to put in because I've got so many uh of
these issues about uh the um repairs and
maintenance from housing associations in
my board and no no counselor alcock's
another area that uh does have a lot
um I've had it for you know year after
year after year uh and particularly this
last winter so if you want uh attendance
who can give you an experience of their
particular problems I'm happy to be able
to ask for people from my area because
I've got about 10 cases that are ongoing
at the moment which I'm sure would be of
interest
so that's just an update for of yourself
from the issues arising from the
overview and scrutiny committee we move
on to Part D which is cabinet committees
and we have none from there
and then part e which is unblock items
and for the items in this section the
reports and recommend recommendations
will be approved on block unless a
request is made to the leader at the
start of the meeting for the item to be
discussed and I've had no requests at
the start of this meeting for any of
those items to be discussed so we move
on those ones all on block do we have to
take a vote on that one or we just move
it no so then Part F other matters
urgent business I don't think we have
any urgent business that I'm aware of so
that means that this meeting is
concluded thank you very much indeed for
your time and thank you
um Annette for coming along for your
first cabinet meeting thank you very
much indeed very much appreciated